الثانيه من فجر الثلاثاء يستفيق سكان غزه
على وقع غارات دون انذار مسبق
سرب من اربعين طائره عسكريه اسرائيليه
تغير على القطاع تنفذ غارات استمرت قرابه
عشرين دقيقه بحسب المعلومات
الجيش الاسرائيلي قال انه استهدف مواقع
ومنشات عسكريه شملت مستودعات تصنيع
صواريخها ومجمعات عسكريه تبعتا لحركه
الجهاد الاسلامي
وبحسب الجيش الاسرائيلي استهدفت العمليه
ايضا حي الشجاعيه في غزه ومناطقه في خان
يونس ورفح
ففي حي التفاح شرقيه مدينه غزه ادت
الغارات الى استشهاد خليل البهتيني قائد
المنطقه الشماليه في سرايا القدس مع زوجته
واطفاله في حي الرمال بغزه ايضا استشهد
طارق عز الدين احد قاده العمل العسكري
بالضفه الغربيه في سرايا القدس
واستشهد امين سر المجلس العسكري لسرايا
القدس جهاد الغنام بغاره على منزله في رفح
ثم عادت اسرائيل واستهدفت عصر الثلاثاء ما
قالت انها خليه في مدينه خان يونس من وحده
الصواريخ المضاده للدروع تابعه لحركه
الجهات الاسلاميه
مناطق غلاف غزه شهدت استنفارا امنيا كبيرا
بالتزامن مع التصعيد الاسرائيلي وفتحت
السلطات الاسرائيليه الملاجئ في كل من
اسدود وعسقلان وبئر السبع مع عمليه اخلاء
[موسيقى]